tens of millions of Americans are
totally fine with a man who is driven
almost purely by racism and second
shuttle your piece of [ __ ]
this is what really got here music 10
million Americans are driven by someone
is entirely in my races I'm like that's
not it
again my issues with Donald Trump are
I'm not against free honest trade I
don't want to tax Ford if they put a
plant in Mexico if they still employ
Americans ok I don't want to punish
people for being successful I don't want
a capital gains tax I have legitimate
grievances with Donald Trump none of
them are Donald Trump is racist I do not
believe that the majority of people
today but here's let's do the math here
real quick okay let me so you can tweet
this out tweet made us crowder I'm gonna
get Ana Kasparian real talk now because
let's do some math here I've not talked
about I've not heard anyone else talking
about this this means if you look at
these maps that a majority of the
bleed-over to Donald Trump are people
who voted for Barack Obama and felt
screwed they didn't vote for Barack
Obama then just grows the colored people
vote Trump they voted Barack Obama in
their own self-interest they felt like
they got screwed and now they voted for
Donald Trump the vast majority of white
Americans voted for Barack Obama and now
the vast majority of Americans are
voting for Donald Trump so you can't say
that these same people because there's a
huge amount of people if you look at
that crossover these people were voting
for progress with Donald Trump but with
Barack Obama and now all of a sudden
they're racist because they pulled a
lever for Trump because you screwed them
you screw them with the taxes on small
businesses you screwed them with a
health care mandate and they couldn't
afford then punish them to force them to
buy health care insurance when they
didn't want to and then raise those
premiums 25% and the people who did
built for Obama who were even more
privileged who didn't have to get put
into the Obama care program so their
premiums go up by 40-something percent
you screwed the progressive Christians
and Catholics who voted for Barack Obama
who you then mandated to pay for
somebody else's abortion you screwed
them by putting Lena Dunham sorry face
or ass I don't know which when she's on
the air and made her a wing of your
party the people who voted for Barack
Bhama a significant amount of them
Donald Trump could not win without
enough of those votes and those people
aren't racist there are a lot of
criticisms to have with Donald Trump and
Schanker little and call people racist
no it's because of you when you call
someone racist when you call them sexist
when you call them homophobic when you
call them transphobic because I don't
want a [ __ ] taking a dump next to
their six-year-old daughter it's some
Charlotte Chuckie Cheese guess what they
pull the lever for Trump after they
voted for Obama you [ __ ] so stop
acting like the only possible motivating
factor here that you could fathom is
racism but you're the kind of guy who
walks into a bar and they don't like you
here because I'm a Turk no it's because
you smell you look like a greasy slick
water buffalo who's drowning amidst the
throes of being swallowed by an anaconda
and you're a dick it's not because
you're brown just like it's not because
Donald Trump's racist Gerald what did
you want to say hey Jared laughing this
video is taken from the full weekly
podcast louder with Crowder subscribe by
clicking it Jarrod's laughing because
he's act he just got shot the loss of
blood is making him delirious who shot
him
guilty